polierte aus madrid mit ihrem
lebensgefährten ein neues leben anfangen
und das land verlassen
vor dem umzug trifft sie auf der straße
eine alte freundin ihrer tochter
sie erzählt dass sie holt das tochter
vor kurzem getroffen hat polierte
erstarrt geht zurück packt ihre koffer
verlässt die wohnung ihres geliebten
nutzen weil ich eine tochter am comer
see getroffen
wir haben uns angeschaut und dann habe
ich sie angesprochen
regisseur pedro almodóvar verfilmt in
polierter drei geschichten aus tricks
von seiner lieblingsautoren alice munros
nicht magst in der dritten geschichte
über wird sich rohletter mit ihrem
eigenen vater
die geschichte um ihren vater bildet im
mittelpunkt und erklärt die anderen
beiden geschichten die autorin monroe
hat die geschichten von einander
getrennt und das leben in seine
einzelnen momente geteilt so kann man es
besser durchschauen was für ein motto
'wer macht es umgekehrt
die velo drama motto 'wer werden von
erkenntnis von schuld und von der darauf
folgenden royer angetrieben was ist
bloss roulette ich habe es mir gut
überlegt sagt mir nicht dass du das erst
jetzt überlegt hast wir planen das seit
fast einem jahr erst gestern hast du
gesagt dass du nicht nach madrid zurück
bist was ist dann plötzlich passiert
regisseur einmal den war interessiert
sich nicht für solche strukturen sondern
für gefühle aber er macht großes kino
ein motto 'wer hat sich gut gehalten
sein kino sieht aus wie zu besten zeiten
und das ist eine kunst